and rip my drift the first one coming
from Adam aka el Diablo from Topeka
Kansas and how his Adam's Pelt is at 80
om RA da m ad am oh damn
don't break my Achy Breaky [ __ ] hard
on him Jen what are you doing Jimin out
we just guess what he looks like from
far away oh wow he's in he's in uh okay
I'm not mad at that denim top now I was
autograph to that jackets been signed by
someone can you zoom in on that
signature please oh that looks like
Kenny Chesney it looks like Kenny
Chesney that's a Kenny Chesney signature
and those are some Michael Jordan Hanes
with a [ __ ] little Adam El Diablo
[ __ ] hanging out the front oh yeah this
guy oh that's swaggy coconut oh damn
that's that [ __ ] download meta that's
uploading that soft that [ __ ]
uploading that software brother I like
it that's the devil's dandruff on that
iPhone here dude I'll pray let me
[ __ ] I'll get from here oh boy dude
I'll [ __ ] do that [ __ ] from here dude
I'll [ __ ] balance that [ __ ] on your
nuts and do it yeah Brody [ __ ] dear
me some coca Heena baby oh dude I'll
[ __ ] balance that [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
kickball and do it right I don't give a
[ __ ] son dude this guy looks like he
looks like he's gonna snort all that
coke and do all his laundry though yeah
that's it that's what that's what's
going on here yeah this isn't a lot he's
gonna get a little high little drunk and
do a shitload of laundry yes it
personally isn't a laundry mat he's in
his underpants suds and does rain oh
yeah dude he looks like uh he looks like
um yeah bro oh I was just think of some
you never have no idea like you know
what the promise you don't I know you're
a drug addict you're zoning off staring
at that [ __ ] cocaine like a psycho it
looks like I was making sure nobody was
taking it you're drooling bro
you were drooling you know what I'm
gonna report this to your Pio officer
yeah and I don't think you should be
around these
or this dick this is your [ __ ] show
do you rob me and you're the one putting
this in front of me I didn't put this in
front so nothing like that this well
first of all this guy done out Jason
Aldean yeah Jason called me [ __ ]
laundrymat doing cocaina wash the [ __ ]
out of a white tee though all honesty Oh
bro looks like he's chasing all dope bro
this dude is obviously trying to get
high as [ __ ] dude he's got some too he's
got a cigar is a hat on a miller lite
bag just got [ __ ] bro does he [ __ ] yes
I know Cain 1997 Johnson or outside of
one who's he [ __ ] though like at this
level you're [ __ ] he looks like yea
slim jims in his pocket he looks like
I've gotta have slim jims yeah it looks
like he definitely does Slim Jim the
suppositories a little capsules yeah bro
that teriyaki brush oh yeah yeah brother
and what's his problem chin yeah what is
he sick oh listen doing laundry is a
bummer I like his attitude I like that
he has drugs there I like that he
dressed up for it
like there's alcohol there I like that
his cell phones there so he's [ __ ] do
a line and read the comments he's doing
long need to hate they call it doing
laundry bro and I like it yeah shut word
shout to [ __ ] uh Jason Aldean for
sending one in though yeah straddle two
garth cooks his brain cells our own the
beesting man bring a shot oh my god what
is else present sakes ah you know bro
going out on Saturday night tells O'Hare
to eros Philippines to an Aerosmith
concert bro got a problem with it on
want Aerosmith this week in Vegas
are you yeah
[Applause]
like yeah
Chen la Souris Jun you like your Smith
you want free tickets because they're
back on tour and it's do that 19 video
he started bragging oh dude I got tasty
dosa threat
cool give them to you because not 1992
you're gonna be old man yeah yeah you
know you're batshit crazy if you think
they sound anything like they you saw
come on really hate it they're gonna be
awesome bro Janie's got a gun thing I
[Music]
feel like we're better than they are
yeah but that's why I dressed up like
that I was a are you okay oh wow I saw
the veins in your neck
cuz I'm Aerosmith thing you [ __ ] oh wow
yeah won't you pipe up a [ __ ] couple
of grams your area on a [ __ ] gram day
and get the [ __ ] out of here I'll go to
that concert I listen to real music
you've never ever brag that you're going
to eros dude I got taste it you said
[ __ ] you bro did it come with a [ __ ]
hot tub time Michigan in 1997 you gonna
watch mrs. Doubtfire afterwards I see
what you're doing here you're trying to
distract us from the fact that you're a
crossdresser you [ __ ] creep I'm an
Aerosmith groupie bro real I dress up
because I knew they're in town I'm
trying to hang out with the boys you
look like daddy do well man we could
sing that down in an elevator
[Music]
that's not it
that's it oh we hit it bro it isn't it
like all notes mm-hmm horn smoke if I
could see it then I could do it I don't
know that one either yeah bro you look
like that was our Kelly [ __ ] idiot it
really yeah if I could see I can believe
it believe you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not
gonna see that at the concert bro
that's why you bought tickets you
thought you didn't see I believe I can
fly and it was like I can't wait bro we
should bring our [ __ ] Space Jam
Jersey yes you [ __ ] morons dude first
of all you know why I'm a hot [ __ ]
chick dude dude looks like a lady I look
like [ __ ] mrs. Doubtfire she did all
the d-ball you look like brandy snap
shot off a [ __ ] Instagram bar you
look [ __ ] horrible
you look like enough McCaig and you look
like a shitty drummer for [ __ ] Motley
Crue do you look at your my Watkins as
if I can look like I hear people are
starting to call the blonde Adam ray
just like Jer what they call them
ultimate power bottom baby look like
Lisa can't draw that's it you look like
in this bro I was like friends if they
made a transvestite fortune of it yeah
you look like Frank's bro bunch of
ladies trying to hide their [ __ ]
[ __ ] in their dress all right we got we
got one more rip my drip miss McKenna me
Morris 25 you get my face off this thing
three more Oh Lord I'm sweating James II
got the meaty fronts Mackenzie got them
one two koppel gobblers at the front
them Cadbury eggs hell yeah man she
looks like a classy lady
due to my fishing right now because I
see a motorboat in the future you feel
me tackle box Benny Benny a box Benny
there's some nice tips there's some nice
tits
I'm staring at my ugly ass then some
nice as it is almost say this have to be
entrapped in a room with seven men for
no [ __ ] fest in here and after you
thinking that Aris mr. with our Kelly
this is a nice you know this is a fresca
she's a nice fresca yeah [ __ ] I told ya
and she's got a nice necklace she has
our arms look nice she okay my oh so you
can look both directions look at each
picture she's looking a different girl
yeah pretty cool right comes done well I
like the fit I like the outfit yep you
can see she cares about ourselves she
really takes care of or something that's
McKenzie Morris when she is all natural
because them things are real real nice
baby can you tell us a little bit about
her please she didn't send much she sent
this picture
okay well then killing it dunk it has a
lot outfits in the back it appears a lot
of choices what's your drip ripped
apparently
I wish they didn't give you recess at
school really I wish I need a break next
thank you can take good kids this why
should stay in school see what happens
we play kickball - you're 34 dude yinz
clean school see what happens we play
freeze tag with your mom going up
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]